foreign
[Music]
hey guys how's it going it's another
episode you know what before I even get
started let me start with this we got
the merch the grower die merch that's on
I'm gonna keep wanting to wear it for
the show and I just forget and now I
remember and I'm pissed Las Vegas I'm
going to be in Las Vegas I'm going to be
in Charlotte North Carolina Knoxville
Cleveland Little Rock Arkansas Nashville
these are the ones coming up soon
Calgary Edmonton
um go to chrysalia.com to get tickets
and that's what's up uh
and besides that I
um welcome to this new episode of
congratulations
[Music]
feels good man I got my um my coffee
from my thing that makes the coffee I
got the app I just hit it and I made it
and I made the coffee myself just by the
touch of a button dude world's Getting
Nuts you can just do stuff with the
touch of a button I made a coffee with
the touch of a button
and uh I can't wait till you can work
out with a touch of a button although I
will say I've been heavy on this workout
train lately
it's been over a month now maybe a month
and a half
um uh it is something that is very cool
it's the only time I'm doing something
and I am literally thinking of
absolutely nothing nothing I'm not even
thinking of working out I'm just there
going through the motions and it is so
awesome because I just have nothing to
think about
and it's an hour plus sometimes where I
can just
I mean I'm doing the most basic thing a
man can do which is just kind of picking
stuff up and putting it down you know
and sweating so hard and I look around
dude and I gotta tell you man people at
the gym they don't really sweat that
hard now some do some do but there's a
lot of casual people that just go in
there to kind of like walk on the
stepper a little bit and then converts
with some people dude not me man I talk
to nobody now yes did I talk to an actor
the other day in the new show hijack of
course I did because I watched hijack
and he was there at the gym and he came
up to me and said that I was really
funny and I said you know what dude you
look like the guy from the show hijack
and he said that's me and I said dude
that show is awesome and it is Apple TV
comes up dude they take the pedigree and
they move it up don't they they take the
streaming services they take everyone
you know you think oh you're streaming
services oh you know oh yeah Netflix Oh
Hulu oh you know Amazon Prime Apple TV
comes up Apple TV apple plus whatever
the heck it's called Apple TV plus apple
plus apple plus what's it called who
cares but you know what I'm talking
about that thing whatever that is
Apple's streaming service it goes like
this well hold the phone a little bit
Paramount plus goes like this will hold
the phone a little bit what about
pedigree right because you go on Netflix
and this is how you pick something from
Netflix you go like this
but you go to Apple TV you go like this
you go to Batman but let's go like this
you go to Amazon you go to Hulu you go
to Netflix you go like this
right and then 10 minutes later go like
this
but that's how it is
but some streaming services that got
that pedigree Max kinda got that
pedigree I like Max because it sounds
like I'm gay I like Max
um I like Max
well I think about the HBO thing that
was the highest pedigree of all thing
they had Game of Thrones they had uh
Eastbound and Down they had Ali G show
they had all the good things
um
but yeah uh uh Real Sports of bro Brian
Gumbel today on Real Sports they had HBO
Brian gum was just underwater when he
talks but I have real Sports we're gonna
be talking about the Minnesota sports
um
so yeah
so I I I put on I watched hijacking you
know I don't they do the thing where
they gotta like Apple TV they released
two or three episodes
and then and then you gotta wait every
week like it's still appointment TV like
how it was when you you know in the 80s
and 90s
so I'm watching it I'm all into it
anyway I see this dude actor fine actor
Max Beasley he's great and uh was like
bro you're this show is awesome my wife
we're hooked and he's like just get
ready it's you know it's a ride and I
was like hell yeah dude and I felt good
you know
it feels good you know the the
it feels good and then it's like you
know I'm like yeah
I I when you like what somebody does
then you and then and then you meet them
you want to let them know I guess which
is what I did and that's what he did too
so hey
but anyway that show's cool finished
Silo so good I found out that people are
really mad at the uh
final episode that's crazy people are
mad at everything dude
it was a great show I love it
um Tim Robbins right uh Rebecca Ferguson
Awesome every time Common's in something
I'm always like oh God the [__]
Commons in it and I don't dislike common
it's just like I don't think any dude
how about this only get actors to do
things and if you want get comedians to
play funny parts but like whenever it's
like oh yeah
Alicia Keys is in it and she like didn't
put makeup on for the role and
everyone's like wow for [__] five
days when it comes out and then everyone
forgets about it
you know what I'm talking about or like
Lenny Kravitz when they put him in the
The Hunger Game Show it's like oh my god
dude you could have really put a banger
dude in there
if comment was played if the guy common
if common whatever I don't know that's
his real name common Johnson if he
actually and dude great rapper don't I'm
not taking anything from him and you
know what he's okay at acting but he's a
rapper dude and I know you can't be a
rapper when you're like in your 50s and
60s because it's like a rapping is a
young man's game but like dude when I
when when common shows up in a [__]
thing dude I go like this here we go
when Lenny Kravitz shows up in a [__]
thing I go like this all right okay
common just rap Lenny Kravitz just split
your pants and let your balls fall out
man when he did that
I want to get away I wanna fly rip blog
took out someone's teeth in the front
row no way the penis goes yay
says nothing that part
um so yeah anyway Silo's a good show now
do the sets look kind of fake yes is
everything Brown yes it's all [__]
Kanye did the costume design yes but
it's a good show yes it is dude are the
things that are unexplained yeah so the
plot was maybe that's what we were mad
about the final episode it's okay dude
I don't know man what people want
anymore
every show kind of sucks just chill
these [__] armchair experts that go
in and was like well you know what this
is actually that's the thing everybody's
a comedy expert you know what I mean
you put up a clip on YouTube people are
like people think this guy's funny dude
you know how many people there are
seven billion
there's that many people
think everybody's funny right
there's people that are straight up dog
[__] and there's gonna be people that I
think are funny
it's subjective dude
you know
um so I don't know what people want like
look I don't think that [__] Adam
Sandler movies are funny but I don't you
know that's just me that doesn't mean
he's not funny that means there's
something wrong with me
there's something wrong with me
I don't think certain comedians are
funny doesn't mean they're not good Adam
Sandler's [__] fantastic
um
funniest guy in the world Nick Swardson
there you go
you know no one funnier Brian Callan
these guys Bobby Lee these guys are
funniest people in the world
um that's what I think
uh uh but yeah you know
uh
so I [__] so I I watch those shows
and then and that's it and I don't care
if they're good or bad dude
and then I want to get into other stuff
too but I also saw the American
Gladiators thing on Netflix guess what
dude I'm gonna come out and say it
you're making too many documentaries
about things
when I first saw it I was like oh cool
and then I watched halfway through like
the third episode I go like this dude
I'm only watching this because I used to
watch the American Gladiators that's so
[__] stupid
that's so dumb what I did I go oh cool
click and I watched the whole thing and
I'm watching this thing and then they're
trying to play up like oh yeah these
guys were juicing these guys did drugs
and like they couldn't hack it and one
guy got fired another guy got fired and
the producers were trying to rip people
off and make money off the actors and
they believed in the franchise not
necessarily the the actors and they
thought that the franchise was a star
not the ACT not not [__] Nitro and
and and and and I'm watching this thing
and for about three episodes I'm like
wow wow okay pretty scandalous and then
I'm like oh but it's actually not it's
just boring and oh oh no [__] dude oh
really
Gemini ice [__] Nitro these big
Behemoth [__] oh oh they did
steroids no get out of here dude really
that's not news a [__] course the
American Gladiators did stero words I
wouldn't I wouldn't watch them if they
didn't how about that Juice It Up
take injections
[__] HDH do the whole steroid
do it all be a chick and do it be a
woman and talk like this
Come On Ice
oh really some of the women who did
American Gladiators were gay and it was
hard for them oh [__]
no [__] no [__] they were gay and
juicing
so I'm watching this [__] thing and
it's like and then one guy took a big
hit and got that was it for him and they
thought Malibu was going to be a big
thing yeah dude
that's not it and oh and the producers
tried to make money
and they were on they were they were
they were pissed off that the actors
were pissed off that didn't get
merchandising
dude this is just
how the biz goes
ah [__] huh
well whatever dude you know nobody died
I'm watching this and I'm like nobody
died
zero people died they just did steroids
this is [__] they're making
documentaries of too many things
dude Netflix will just [__] straight
put out
the garbage man conspiracy on [__]
Main Street and in [__] Seattle and
you're like what
and the whole [__] show was just
and then one guy you know they start too
early and they wake me up all the time
garbage man conspiracy
on Netflix
Eight Episodes
and people just eat watch oh oh really
oh so they don't even really put the
plastic in the recycling dude did you
hear a garbage man conspiracy did you
know they don't put the plastic in the
[__] thing ever since [__] to make
a murderer or whatever the hell it is
or uh who wants to be a murderer or
whatever the [__]
with the [__] guy it's like dude that
was so one-sided the guy so obviously
went stabbing and Netflix was trying to
make it like and there's [__] out
here that are just like we gotta free
the guy who [__] stabbed
Gary you Google one [__] thing about
that thing and it's like oh but why did
Netflix leave the part where there were
[__] chains on his bed with handcuffs
could be a kink could be but I'm just
saying dude
anyway so I'm uh it's like
I'd rather just watch the [__] uh
you know and one day I was murdered or
whatever those things are in every
episode it's like about a neighbor
um
but yeah there was one unbelievable
story about the the American Gladiator
in that thing the dude Nitro really
handsome dude
um and this is just so telling
about
um
how Insidious trauma is right like when
you're a kid when you're growing up like
we've all had some sort of trauma and
um Pia Melody
who basically wrote the book on
childhood drama was she did write books
on childhood drama but
she says anything less than nurturing is
trauma and I don't know if I believe
that but everything affects you when
you're [__] five so in a way I
understand what she's saying
um but this dude basically this kid
Nitro when he was a kid was ripped from
his mom his dad took him and he had to
leave his mom because his dad was gonna
take custody of him so he was getting on
the plane leaving his mom and his mom
was weeping and he was crying so much
right I don't know how old he was young
but this guy who saw the kid and said
hey buddy are you crying and he said
yeah and he says let me see your muscle
and the guy goes like this and he points
to it and he says you got a little
muscle right there that means you're a
man and Men Don't Cry
that [__] thing this guy he's 58 now
and he remembers that and that's I would
argue the reason he got big and jacked
and became American Gladiator isn't that
[__] insane and now he dude his
brother died years later and he didn't
cry he was like I'm not supposed to cry
because that guy said he was still a kid
but dude that [__] that little grain of
sand plucked into that dude's brain grew
to be a whole [__]
and now it's [__] up
but
foreign Hopefully the guy knows and the
guy did therapy and the guy's [__] a
little bit better for it now because man
here's the other [__] crazy thing
dude that guy who told that kid Nitro as
a kid that isn't a bad guy he thought he
was helping that's the most [__] up
like you don't even get to be like as an
adult as nitro you don't even get to be
like [__] that guy he's evil you got to
be like oh I was only trying his best
and now I'm [__] up
as you're on the [__] the jousting
eyes are in the big ball like a [__]
big muscular hamster
yeah dude it's crazy trauma what it does
man
I had some yes dude so anyway I try to
like think about that with my kids man
dude I try to think about it with my
kids
um
yeah a lot of stuff man every dude if
you don't make a TV show or a movie and
have the character be really like have
he had some trauma in his past you ain't
[__] dude
your show is for the birds did you know
that
I watched the dawn wall a lot of stuff
I'm talking about a lot of watching a
lot of stuff and I don't even
but man it's a [__] rock oh dude well
let me just start with this I want rock
climbing
well bouldering
it's inside it's not higher than 30 feet
but you don't have to [__] rub
yourself in and there's a big mat that
even if you fall you do kind of get hurt
sometimes
and I did I didn't realize how hard it
was and I have [__] six blisters on
my inside of my hands oh yes dude
and it hurts do I still push through and
work out yes have I yes does it hurt yes
do I bleed all over the weights yes do I
watch them after no but I you know I
don't I don't believe
I got right here see boom boom boom boom
um anyway
um
a show I went rock climbing with the
family
well not rock climbing bouldering with
Kristen
uh two friends Calvin and we even
brought William dude and they made
William sign a waiver
he's not even three months
they're like I know it's kind of silly
but just do it for him more luck
this kid shoots his pants oh he's not
gonna be climbing
do I say okay so I went there dude
and uh he says what size shoe I said 13
he's like I'm gonna give you 13 and a
half they run a little small so I said
okay
all right they were so small so I said
hey man give me 14. so small I said hey
man can get a 15. started doing a little
bit so small hey Mac I get a 16 what's
the deal here I need a size 16 rock
climbing shoe on the man dude
[__] man I got big ass rock
climb my feet
but anyway dude it was fun
got ripped to shreds
um my wife saw his [__] dude she killed
it
because she's a gymnast dude she was
just like
just like Frodo on on the [__] thing
just Spider-Man like the horror movies
when the somebody's in the corner just
up in the ceiling like this
and then you turn the light on they're
not there
[__] hate horror movies I love horror
movies but I can't stand they all do the
thing I watched that new one on Netflix
Run Rabbit Run the second the the kid
Drew dark pictures with I'm out dude how
many kids are gonna draw scribbly
pictures of their family
and like in a demonic way and they go
like you know the the little Johnny
wrote he drew this and he go oh no and
it I'm out I'm out
foreign
so uh we went bouldering and it was fun
it was fun it's really hard dude it's
really hard man it's so hard and you
know me dude when I try something I get
obsessed with it so what I do I left
after you know a few hours
one or two hours
and not long and uh
but I felt good you know and then I
watched friggin 2 documentaries on rock
climbing
he's an addict folks he does one thing
and he does it and then he does it
forever
uh so the dawn wall it's free solo I saw
which by the way I am going to tell this
right now I didn't like free solo oopsie
Daisy everybody gets mad when I say this
why because the Dude is quite obviously
a goddamn sociopath you don't feel for
him because he doesn't feel for anybody
dude the guy goes like this hey I love
you to a new chick that he was with and
then she says I love you too uh he says
gotta got a free solo though and she's
like what if you die and he goes I I
don't have to tell you I gotta just get
up there she's like but he's like Adam
Carrie leave me
that's just about
so
um
but that sociopaths make up for in grip
strength I'll tell you that much so I
watched the dawn wall which is about
this dude man who when he was a kid dude
he got abducted by [__] like uh
Afghani soldiers while he was trying to
rock climb and Kurdistan I don't know
where anything is but um
because I'm racist and uh and he was
doing it and they and they took him and
his girlfriend and the one guy went off
to get food and then the dude was with
his girlfriend and the dude that was
watching them
from the Army or whatever it was I don't
know anything uh he he says to his so
the guy
who says to his girlfriend
hey I'm gonna have to push him off the
ledge otherwise you know he's going to
kill us and she was like he's like I
have to do that and she didn't say
anything and he was like I took that as
she would be okay with it
so he [__]
pushed the guy off the ledge and the guy
died
he had to [__] dude I thought I was
watching a rock climbing documentary and
it's still a documentary about murder my
wife watches that [__] all the time do
you know what I'm saying and I'm like
always trying to get away from the
murder documentaries I thought I put on
like a happy-go-lucky friendly rock
climbing movie this guy still is a
murderer
unbelievable but it was either him or
him and he took care of it and then they
trauma bonded him and his wife and they
got married they loved each other and
then they ended up breaking up because
they say people who meet under high
pressure situations they don't
necessarily work out all that way and
when we learned that well we learn that
from where we learn that from speed
right Cassandra Bullock says that took
generals all the time
um
so anyway
they're rock climbing now and this guy
is like
survived that that's obviously shaped
them right
dude you got trauma like that you're
congratulations you're shaped
right
ah [__] you had to kill somebody's to to
save your and your love's wife oh [__]
you're done got shaped
right
that's what happens
you see a car accident when you're six
whoopsie you got shaped
you got a babysitter that tried to do
some [__] with you oh you didn't get
shaped
this guy had to throw someone off a
cliff in Kurdistan whoopsie he shaped
forever so now the dude is like killer
rock climber the best rock climber
starts doing really well so he's killing
a rock climbing and then he's building
something and doing using one of those
saws cuts off his finger more trauma and
his supposed rock climbing career got
thrown out the window because now he's
one figure less dude's got nine fingers
the only thing you need is a rock
climber is fingers you don't even need
eyes there's a blind one I swear to God
I saw a blind one on the documentary he
was just feeling around like this
it's just like [__] Ray Charles out
there just oh there's a spot and Clement
he's still alive so all you need are
fingers and this dude got his finger cut
off and guess what that did instead of
ruined his career
shaped them
he goes like this extra trauma scoop
that up let me get all shaped up
so this guy became I [__] you not a
better rock climber dude better than
anyone better than his past self he was
doing [__] he's never done before and
guess what dude he never would have been
able to do that if he didn't push a guy
off a [__] cliff when he was younger
and kill them because that shaped his
mentality dude
you could either be a victim or you
could done get [__] shaped
that's why we say grow or die baby
we gotta find the guy's name but it's so
disrespectful if I don't know the guy's
name
um the dawn wall
uh Tommy Caldwell best note so so I'm
watching the dawn wall and I'm like this
is the documentary app [__] people
watching free solo I got all the awards
oh [__] all [__] out of here with that
[__] this is what I want to talk about I
want to watch this guy because he's got
the personality baby and you know look
let's face it if you're a rock climber
you're gonna be [__] weird right you
just got to be a goddamn weirdo
hey what you do climb and you're not
seven
you create you got to be an introvert
weird or autistic kind of guy I don't
even mean that to be funny it's just
such a specific thing to just keep
climbing rocks
yeah
um so man I did not realize how much
grip strength they need I mean I I gotta
I gotta use like this and these dudes
are just like these dudes are just they
rock climb they're like this they go
like this
fingers and holes and I'm just like wow
dude
so uh
uh yeah
uh
I'm sorry I tried it I try to do it I'm
not I'm not good at it but I'm gonna go
again we mean why my wife want to go
again Calvin was on there on the little
ones it was really cute really cute
um
God isn't it you know what I was waiting
for is the cow the the the the day
like
there was somebody in my family I
remember who it was but then when they
were younger really younger when they
saw their first Asian person
they looked at them and they went ching
chong ching chong ching chong and it was
like they were you know three you don't
know better and you're like oh my God oh
God
it's so racist you know but but they're
also three and it's just a society
that's showing them a cartoon or
something and now that's what they do oh
[__] it
so I mean that's so bad God but keep
with the kids
um
anyway I was like what's what's gonna
happen when Cal because like we expose
him to you you know you want to expose
like we don't always buy the white
action figures or the you know what I
mean like we wanna
you know and in his school he's got it's
it's a you know it's a bit of a Melting
Pot and like thank God you know because
we don't we want him to be exposed to
every kind of looking person
because God forbid you know they [__]
grow up only with one type of person and
then they they think people are look
people are different and that's okay but
anyway
was on a walk with Calvin
and this like beautiful tall
dark
woman walked by uh with uh and she was
maybe like
I don't know what she was really not
African-American if you can't even say
that nowadays but like uh something else
I don't know because I'm a white guy
um
and she walked by and Calvin said let me
let me get this quote right Calvin said
um
uh
she's brown like Sheriff toaster and has
boobs like Mommy
and you know what
he was right
Google sheriff toadster sheriff
toadsters Brown he's from the [__]
video game that he plays
and that woman was Brown
and she had boobies like Mommy
so
what can you do
for my money it's better than ching
chong ching chong when you see an Asian
so
oh yeah yeah yeah
that's what I did
yeah she's
Brown like you're Brown like sorry man
but I don't I wouldn't have said it but
he actually does you are brown like
Sheriff toadster
and you know my wife has boobies uh so
anyway it was nice to meet you uh come
on Calvin let's go
[Music]
so I'm like oh it happened the thing
happened
and that's a good one Sheriff toadster
you know
um
been working out I [__] worked David
out hard dude
you know he I made him do we did box
jumpsuits after we were doing uh chest
workouts and he jumped off the box and I
was like we gotta go into a push-up we
jumped out the box oh and couldn't do a
push-up almost broke his [__] nose on
the ground it was amazing
and uh
I don't realize I go [__] hard dude
but I do
and uh
and when I would and then and then he
was so
[__] up afterwards like just so tired
you know when like you're just at you're
just your hearts beating and you're and
you know there's a food place right next
to you and you're trying to get food and
he was just talking and he was like
talking about how he used to go to
school
uh and and uh because he used to play
football uh and he used to be a kicker
um a really good kicker
and uh at Baylor Baylor yeah Baylor
Baylor football and uh he played with JJ
Watt
is that his name
and um
and he was telling me a story about how
JJ Watt said to me that if you work out
basically you can eat lean protein
anytime and then he kept talking about
JJ Watt
and he was doing like this jokey thing
where he was talking about him
and saying like acting like they were
best friends you know how like [__]
how Brian Callum will do that about like
you know Tom Cruise or some [__] when he
doesn't know him but obviously
David knew JJ Watt a little bit but
anyway
and he didn't realize it but he was
calling him
JJ protein a bunch
and he was like that's what JJ protein
said man but he was good man JJ protein
and I'm like hey man
you're saying JJ pro team and he said
what
and I said it's JJ Watt and you know
that and you're saying JJ protein and he
said ah [__] I had no idea he was so
worked out that he was just calling him
JJ protein and that that
that's the funniest thing that's ever
happened so there that's it
was so good dude [__] idiot you know
come on plug in
um
my wife was like she was like telling me
to go get I was working out and then she
was like go get can you go pick up she's
so great dude she's got this book club
that I joined and she was reading now
she's reading Oprah's Book on it like a
bunch of people joined and she's like
posts about it [__] love it
um
and uh
she was like can you go get these photos
that I printed out at Walgreens and I go
like this yeah you know why good dude
right
so go to do it and she was like and I
get there and the guy's like it's gonna
be about 15 minutes so I was like she
told me prematurely all good no big deal
I'll walk across the street to Starbucks
so I do and
um
I go to a Starbucks that I haven't been
to in a while years I used to go there a
bunch I lived in there there wow I
actually lived near there and just
thought about it Jesus
wow that'll be a trip to go back to
those apartments
anyway
I walk into the Starbucks first of all
on the patio no furniture which there's
always like people hanging out I walk
inside no furniture no furniture in
Starbucks but it's well open
so I walk up man I'm gonna get a coffee
already no actually no I want to get a
salad
and they don't have salad so I'm like oh
now I came here for no reason and I'm
pissed but at least I can gain
information I'm curious where the [__]
is the furniture so I say to the lady
hey
um
why is there no furniture in here and
she said man
we've been having so many incidents
that upper management just told us we
can't have furniture
about it we can't even have furniture
anymore because we can't have people in
here and I was like so you just
you just you can come in and sell and
get coffee and you got a leaf and she's
like yeah
I'm like whoa dude
the world is going to [__]
Starbucks can't even have furniture
anymore
what are incidents too you know it has
to do with like homeless people [__]
on the floor and like fights
like fighting and
oh God
oh my god dude
this is so crazy
they can't have furniture stop asking
furniture anymore
it wasn't even like it was like Vineland
and Ventura
it was just some place that you might be
like oh cool Starbucks you're going no
furniture
I should have just sat on the floor and
drank a [__] iced espresso
um absolutely bonkers
bro what's with this [__] uh
uh Elon Musk now is putting
the new paywall on Twitter where you
need an account just to retweets now
which is cool whatever and you have to
pay for Twitter blue verified access to
see more than 600 posts per day and if
you don't have that you can only see 600
posts or less
and wow I think that'll change things
right I don't know how many I don't look
at Twitter but like how many posts do
you typically see in a day
I would think I well I don't use it so
I'm a bad judge of it but
I would think
no there's probably people who [__]
see thousands right there's probably
people that scroll all day you're not
gonna be able to do that unless you pay
which you'll pay probably
but Elon Musk continues to blame
Twitter's new limitations on AI
companies scrapping vast amount of data
as he announced new temporary limits
atom board
and I'm bored
oh wait hold on
and for new unverified accounts it's
just 300 in a day
yeah people with no Twitter account can
never see a tweet but are there people
that look at Twitter that don't have
Twitter
oh yeah because you don't have Twitter
if I wanted you to S if I had Twitter
and you didn't and I wanted you to see a
link with Twitter you can't
be a lot more screenshotting dude
um the limits for verified accounts
presumably whether they're bought as a
part of Twitter blue subscription
granted through an organization or
verification you'll enforce some people
like Stephen King LeBron James and
anyone else
um still allow reading only a maximum of
6 000 posts a day okay
um
okay well God bless I mean Twitter's the
worst
um
but it is a link that somebody sent me
that was the reason why I found out
that uh
uh Michael Jordan's son is now dating
Scottie Pippins
and that dude there is nothing honestly
nothing uh more [__] gangster than
that
you know what I mean like as if Scottie
Pippen like dude he's been through
enough you know
he's been through enough he was the
second banana
on the [__] bulls he played with the
goat probably would have been considered
a goat I'm sure he is but now that
Michael Jordan exists and not even that
on the same team so it gets overshadowed
and now
however many years ago nutted in someone
made a kid that kid grew up and is now
blasting his uh the [__] guy who got
overshadow his ex-wife and that if that
is dude is this the Chicago Bulls or
Game of Thrones
this is absolutely crazy that this
happened
so that's the most gangster thing I've
ever seen in my life and Michael Jordan
has said hell no I don't approve of sun
dating Larsa Pippin Larsa is the worst
name of all time we all know that right
he's not Larissa it's Larsa says
horrible
um
but that's what TMZ reports and we know
that they always tell the goddamn truth
but Michael Jordan has never been want
to mention here we go
hey Mr
come on
great internet
what do you think about Marcus and lots
of people together
he laughed let's let it load dude he
laughed
he laughed
you don't approve
do you think he's going to ask her to
marry him
he just said no
these vultures
[Music]
wow
that was a bad video dude I have really
these vultures dude this sucks
but they got hot and steamy how old is a
Michael Jordan's son
is
33. 32 and how old is she
48.
wow
I had probably some [__]
that's probably some [__] up [__]
there huh
yeah I just went pee-pee
um
by the way there's video on my other
channel Chris D'Elia
um the YouTube channel I put up video of
me doing some some crowd work stand up
um I released it I talked about it last
uh week and it's out there now so you
can go check it out
um and like And subscribe here that
would be great I would appreciate it and
leave a comment
um and I didn't even realize that okay
so it's Monday now which means this
comes out for patreon on Wednesday which
means that for Thursday it comes out
regular YouTube so if you're a patreon
member thank you very much if you're not
patreon.com crystalia but uh yesterday
or two days ago depending when you
listen to this or if you listen to the
weekend this past week it was uh Fourth
of July I didn't even uh
I'm not a you know holidays are cool but
like you know I don't want to do too
much [__] you know me
um and my wife
so my wife was like what do you want to
do for Fourth of July and I was like ah
just watch fireworks but like
comfortably you know I don't want to be
too hot I don't have to be like this
beforehand because the sun's out a lot I
don't want to be around too many people
last year we went to University or wait
Disneyland which was sweet
um Calvin saw his first fireworks but um
she was like
we can do a few things the Dodgers play
the Pirates or something we can go do
that and I'm like that's out because
it's gonna be too sunny and then too
much and then Calvin and we're gonna
bring William to football games too much
old
she says you wanna go to uh the the
Hollywood Bowl and watch The Beach Boys
sing and then fireworks and I think and
I go well that's not as bad as the
baseball one but holy [__] [__] you
know what I mean The Beach Boys no like
I get it they had some hits but also
ah also Calvin's not gonna like that
[__] you know Calvin's gonna be sit
there and I'm gonna be like yeah you
like this song wouldn't it be nice to be
together actually that shit's corny as
[__] those songs huh
I don't even know any other Beach but
Beach Boys songs actually
um what else whatever but they made you
know you know him if you heard them but
uh yeah so I'm like I don't want to do
that Calvin's not gonna like that and
then we were like Calvin want to go look
at fireworks we showed him some
fireworks and he was like no
and we were like whoa what the [__] and
he was like I said why is it because I'm
scared of it and we're like you've seen
him before last year
and he was just like I don't want to do
it what do you want what do you want to
do for Fourth of July and he said
this is his wife's or my wife's son he
said
stay home and deck away
dude he's three he's already talking
about staying home and decorating which
is cool to stay home part
and also the white the stay home part
was for Dad and the decorate part was
for Mom dude he's half above of us
so it's beautiful
um but uh
I don't know didn't you give me an
option you just want to go on a picnic
and I'm like would you stop right there
yes that's the move dude that's the most
American [__] dude and you know I'm a
hot blood American man I'm a hot blood
American
you know what I mean I love Tabasco
sauce and [__] burgers and you know I
get boners every now and I'm a red blood
American dude that's what's up so we're
gonna go do that a picnic so we did that
so it was fun probably but
I don't know about fourth of uh July you
know it's Americans celebrating its
independence and then so everyone just
gets drunk and [__] and sets off
fireworks and loses fingers
um
fireworks everything's scary to me dude
I don't want fireworks I don't want to
hold them sparklers are okay actually I
gotta get some sparklers for Calvin that
will be [__] amazing
but um
we thought about going on a boat we
thought about and everything's just
[__] I'm like babe this [__] is just
money I mean I know no dents but also
like let's just make a sandwich and
watch fireworks dude
on YouTube like not even live
um
I don't know let's do some deserved
scales here
's one
um on Instagram
oh no
it's a little person is that what they
call them
I don't know anymore put it on oh [__]
out the door oh [__] out the door little
guy you know what had a little [__]
dump truck on him you know you don't
realize this but a lot of times little
people they got some [__] crazy
weight on the bottom half of them
he's got a [__] dump truck you know
what I'm saying you see little people
sometimes
they used to call them midgets right but
now you don't anymore because just times
change and you decide one word isn't
right but dude
they got dump trucks on them like if
they do turned around it looked like
[__]
you know what I'm saying two watermelons
in his back but this dude goes to jump
on a dudes
and he's drunk the other dude not the
little person but he's like all right
let's do it
give him
give him a hug and then he goes jump on
my back which by the way I would
strangle the guy if I was a little
person and they go jump on my back I go
like this okay turn around and then
strangle the person I'd be like Tap Out
[__] you just let a little dude
hit you up
and then he jumps on his back
and just can't even and they went out
the door now they're in another room
dude that's how gangster that was
unbelievable
that's cool dude but God damn it hit
that emergency exit like there was a
fire
um deserve it scale
100 percent
um
eight you know definitely an eight
here's another one actions come with
consequences
uh
let's see what
oh this one's a minute long but let's
let's get into it dude
oh there's no there's no sound on it
the worst sound of all time
guys walking over down to the lake
oh man look at these dudes death in a
Chicago Bears fans
um yeah
following somebody I guess
whites
cross the lawn oh [__] watch out
oh no he threw a piece of mud at this
guy's window
and it broke oh it's rocks holy [__]
dude this is some old people [__] the
[__] dude rolled up on a golf cart
and just straight up ran the dude over
that's attempted murder Maybe
[Music]
I'm dying
I wonder what happened
oh he's doing it at one house and then
another house oh she's a crazy guy I
guess
oh my God the build up to this is
awesome
oh my god dude
so he picks up why wouldn't the [__]
dudes tackle it they're too fat you know
it's like it's so hot out and they're
like this is he
the cops are coming obviously [__] watch
out
oh hit the side of the thing and then
throws one
breaks the window dude watch like a bat
out of hell dude Batman
oh dude there we go this is so
this is the whitest thing ever
you know
God's acting up getting golf cart
park it
[Music]
away
and then just says I'm dying
wow this is crazy
he ran him they didn't just hit him he
was just like ah we keep going nowhere
we keep going here in Gainesville
holy [__] all right let's do another one
that was uh you know what dude don't
throw rocks in people's windows also
those are like Boulders they weren't
even just rocks you know rare very
rarely do people get exactly what they
deserve I don't know if that was a
little harsh but yeah uh you kind of
deserved it right deserve a scale
eight
here we go it's another one
oh hold on
she got shorter with that one
she hit her head
oh she's laughing but she's gonna show
her tomorrow look getting on the
chandelier what a [__] good
and that's a 10.
[Music]
we're inside this song made it a ten
this song made it done with the [__]
ukulele [__] [__] in the back
this idiot is just climbing the [__]
Chandelier
I hate sauce whatever [__] who sings
so many people sing like that
boom look and that was the moment I
realized I [__] up I became shorter
after that because my whole spine
truncated oh yeah
that's a 10.
the music unreal dude the music killed
it there great soundtrack for that one
see another one that was a 10. so eight
eight ten
wow we love deserve scales man
okay here we go here's another one
oh God guys got a bat
what is it a cat
the kind of squirrel is in this guys
oh [__] that's cool
is that Sonic had a hedgehog
come on bro man the [__] up
that's hardly a deserved scale but the
guy's a [__] guy hey breathe you know
what I mean
yeah why does he have a [__] bat next
to his desk
that's also so white
God whites are the best with the dessert
skill I hate to say it because I'm white
but
us [__] dude that's not a
deserve itself technically but I am
happy I saw it
who screams like that I couldn't even
scream like that if I tried all right uh
missed connections ATM inside La ATM
male accepting big straight deposits
hahaha
oh my God you know what to do all right
let's show concise right to the point
ATM mail
ATM mail accepting big straight deposits
so you want he wants you to not like
guys but still give him a deposit
straight
um here's another one you used to give
us your used condoms too many used in
that
sentence and also disgusting we lost you
you used to give us your filled condoms
so my wife and I could play with it oh
my god dude
I would give you pics of her in exchange
bad deal
hey guy
negotiate is there any world where I
don't have to accept the condoms that
are have come in it
or no okay here are the pictures of my
naked wife
bad deal dude worst negotiator you know
who we need for this what
you know what I'm talking about Mr used
condoms ah [__] we've got the hostage
situation all right all right I'll
handle it
hey it's uh
uh how you doing in there good but I'm
gonna kill everyone or I want to Chopper
all right all right we'll get to that
Chopper
um any chance if I slide some directs
under here you could fill them up
I need to play with them with my wife
I only got one dick yeah but the
hostages I don't really care whose it is
[Laughter]
get the chopper he's gonna let him go
you're gonna let the guys go just let me
play around with them [__] used
condoms
oh my God the world
here we go guy looking for fun with girl
Linwood looking for a girl that wants to
have some fun I come over then leave
after we're done having fun so
oh that's a haiku that's pretty good
straightforward
girls gonna want more after that though
you know
just gonna want more after that
that doesn't exist
you might think it does but it doesn't
and if it does she'll be disgusting and
fat anyway
um here we go cookies and donut
don't it's uh spelled d-o-u-n-t so I
mean the proofreading on this is just
off the charts Granada Hills
hey there I have a bit of a sweet tooth
and am looking to eat a nice cookie and
donut female only
I guess that means you know both
privates front and back door
hey neither a bit of sweet I just did
the length of the [__]
so I have a bit of a sweet tooth you
bend over
I'll get my nose all wet um who needs uh
nice plunge of the rear okay these are
dude I'm done I mean dude who needs uh
and then in the body nice plunge of the
rear I'd love to help so let me know
when and where this is for now 3am
this is for now
hey anyone need a nice plunge of the
rear
if so
save your filled up condoms me and my
wife needs to play with them
um all right dude that was missed
connections holy [__] thank you for
listening thank you for watching if you
want sign up for our patreon patreon.com
slash Chris D'Elia
um and then also I always I I forget to
plug this a lot but uh 15 off pure
Spectrum CBD use cone congrats at
checkout so we have uh at pure Spectrum
tcbd which is uh let's see pure Spectrum
it's a good deal and this stuff works it
definitely works for my um
Restless
uh legs syndrome
I take this I don't have restless leg
syndrome and that's the truth but uh
yeah you can go to uh the website is
purespectrumcbd.com and you type in
congrats at checkout there it is
purespectrumcbd.com and uh you get 15
off so that's awesome so go do that for
your CBD needs if you have rest assigned
legs syndrome try this it's supposed to
take like a week or two to work or a
month or something but man the second I
if I take this in the day my legs don't
go crazy if I don't they do so thank you
very much you guys appreciate you rock
on
[Music]
thank you